قال رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان عبد
الفتاح البرهان انه لم يكن يتصور ان تمتد
مسماها يد الغد والخيانه من قيادات قوات
الدعم السريع الى درجه تفجير الحرب
الحاليه وفرضها على الجيش والحكومه بحسب
قوله يتزامن خطاب البرهان الذي القاه
بمناسبه عيد الجيش مع استمرار الاشتباكات
في العاصمه وجنوب دارفور ومع مواجهات اخرى
في جنوب كردفان
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما اهم الرسائل التي
حملها خطاب البرهان في عيد الجيش وما الذي
يضيفه هذا الخطاب للمشهد السوداني مع
اشتداد المعارك مع الدعم السريع ما دلاله
خلو خطاب البرهان من اي اشاره الى الحوار
مع الدعم السريع وما مستقبل تسويه الازمه
بالطرق السلميه على ضوء ذلك ما المسارات
المحتمله للازمه السودانيه بالنظر
للتطورات الميدانيه المتلاحقه في العاصمه
ودارفور وجنوب كردفان واكمال الحرب شهرها
الرابع
[موسيقى]
في اليوم الاخير من الشهر الرابع للحرب في
السودان بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
والذي يصادف الذكرى التاسعه والستين
لسودنه قياده الجيش كان رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
جمله من الاتهامات لقياده قوات الدعم
السريع التي حملها مسؤوليه تفجير الحرب
الحاليه ضد الحكومه والجيش وقياده ما
سماها اكبر مؤامره يتعرض لها السودان طوال
تاريخه الحديث
بلادنا تواجه اكبر مؤامره في تاريخها
الحديث
تستهدف كيان وهويه وتراث مصير شعبنا الذي
ظل منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي
يواجه بالصبر وايمان ابشع فصول الارهاب
على ايدي مليجي المتمرد الخائن واعوانه
الذين قادوا اكبر ظاهره قامت على التضليل
والكذب والخداع وتزييف الحقائق وشيرازي
وما الناس في تاريخ هذا البلد تحت لافته
ورايه زيف مؤسسه تسمى بالدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
يبدو البرهان اكثر هدوءا واثقه في خطابها
هذا ويختلف اختلاف تماما
يختلف اختلاف كلي من خطابات البرهان في
بدايات الحرب يعني
[موسيقى]
حتى قرارات البرهان فيما يخص الدعم السريع
كان الناس يتساءلون لماذا تاخر البرهان
لفتره طويله جدا في اقاله نائبه حميتيه
يعني من مجلس السياده لماذا لا يوصف الدعم
السريع بانه متمرد وكذا
فالان البرهان اكثر ثقه وهو يطلق لفظ
التمرد وهذا هو التوصيف الصحيح لهذه الحرب
يعني اخيرا هو اوصف هذه الحرب وصفا صحيحا
ثم اشار الى المؤامره لانه هنالك اطراف
كثر تداخلوا في في هذه الحرب وما زالوا
يغزون هذه الحرب ويديمون نعم تفضل لماذا
اخذه اربعه اشهر ليوصف الحاله هكذا
هنالك غياب للاداره المدنيه لهذه الحرب
يعني الجيش منشغل بالمعارك انشغال شديد
جدا في الخرطوم تغيب الاداره المدنيه
للحرب واضح انه حده المعارك في الايام
الاولى كانت كثيره جدا الى ان تمكن الجيش
من امتصاص الصدمه تغير الخطاب بعض امتصاص
الصدمه وبدات جيش رويدا رويدا يعني عبر
قائده يرسل هذه الرسائل الصحيحه في في
بريد المتلقين ان كان مجتمع دولي او ان
كان للشعب السوداني او كين للجيش وافراده
خصوصا ان هذه مناسبه عيد الجيش
فتوصيف هذا الصراع توصيفا صحيحا بانه تمرد
على مؤسسه الجيش التي وصل عمرها الى 69
عام في هذا اليوم
طيب سيد عمران قال الدكتور عيدروس بانه
خطاب هادئ ولكنه ناري على صعيد اطلاق
التهم اتهم الدعم السريع والسيد حميدتي
باكبر مؤامره الغدر الخداع جر بلاد نحو
حرب والى اخره كيف تردون على اتهامات
السيد البرهان
البدء السلام عليكم ورحمه الله التحيه لك
ولضيفك ولكل المشاهدين قناه الجزيره انا
اختلف تماما مع ضيفك في وصفه لخفاض
البرهان خطاب البرهان زيد الفاضل لم ياتي
بجديد خطاب يعني هذه وخجول يعني بدلا من
ان يطلبوا يعتذر للشعب السوداني عن هذه
المعاناه التي قام بها ظنا منه
سيستطيع القضاء على الدعم السريع في
سويعات الان في شعر الرابع وهو لحتى لا
يستطيع
ان يحمي من مخباه كيف
بعيد التاسع وستين للجيش وهنالك الجثث
الجيش ما زالت ملقيه في في في الاراء هذا
كله تناقض البرهان بدا بوصف بكلمات يصف
فيها المؤامره الكبرى نحن من نقول ان
هنالك مؤامره والمؤامره هو يعرفها جيدا
والشعب السوداني يعرفها وكانت جليه في شهر
رمضان المبارك انما كان النظام السابقه
اعلنها صراحه في في الافصالات الجماعيه
التي يقوم بها وقد وضعها ذلك انس عمر
والجزولي في خطاباتهم الذي اصره تماما انه
كان لانقلاب وكان ورائهم الجيش يعني ايضا
هنالك منسوبين للنظام السابق قاموا بحشود
جيوشهم وجنودهم مثل القطائب البراء فكل
هذه هي تلك هي المؤامره التي دبرت
لقطع دابر الثوره المجيده التي قام بها
الشعب السوداني ايضا
هذا الشعب سيدي الفاضل هو الحكم المدني
الديمقراطي البرهن انه هو من انقلب على
على الحكم البدني الديمقراطي على الثوره
المجيده التي جاءت هو من انقلب في 25
اكتوبر
والخيار الخيار الشعب المدني الخيار
الخيار المدني تحدث به هؤلاء الشباب هؤلاء
السوار في الشباب
ونائبا للسيد البرهان خلال هذه الفتره
والمسار السياسي الذي فشل اكثر من مناسبه
نعم
نعمتي كان نائبا للبرهان ولم يكن هو هو في
مقدمه راس الرمح وهو البهاق هو يعمل بع
مره اذا البرهان هو
انت سيد المشهد لكن حتى في مؤامره 25
اكتوبر والانقلاب عندما جاء به يعني الشعب
السوداني بانه يريد توسيع معونه المشاركه
لذلك رضي الشعب رضي السيد حميتي وكل
الذين معه لكن اتضح جليا بعد ذلك انه اراد
ان يبعد القوه السياسيه وياتي بالنظام
السابق لذلك اعترضه السيد القائد الدعم
السريع واكد ان هذا انقلاب قد اعتزل للشعب
السوداني لكن للاسف حتى الان حتى الان
برهان يعني يزير الرواد في العيون يخضع
الشعب السوداني يكذب له ليل ونهاب يريد ان
يضلله ان يبرر تلك الماساه التي قام بها
بغير
اكيد الكل يتحمل المسؤوليه في السودان عما
حصل في يوم 15 ابريل وتفجرت هذه الحرب لكن
لا يمكن توصيف الحرب بغير توصيفه الصحيح
انه الدعم السريع
وجد انه بعد الثوره دخل في شراكه مع
المدنيين هو والجيش اصبح
المانحين للسلطه للمدنيين والوصيين تقريبا
على كل تفاصيل
السلطه والحكم الانتقالي الذي يعني يعني
جاء بعد الثوره
لهذا يعني كما انهم هم المانحين للسلطه
اخذوا السلطه مره اخرى في 25 اكتوبر وابعد
المدنيين الذين تحالفوا معهم في الوثيقه
الدستوريه للاسف انه المدنيين في السودان
انفسهم لم يتعلموا الدرس الاول وانه هذه
السلطه لا يمنحها الجيش ولا الدعم السريع
ولا تمنحها القوه العسكريه هذه السلطه ملك
للشعب السوداني يمنحها الشعب السوداني
القوه المدنيه رجعت مره اخرى الى الجيش
والى الدعم السريع لتوقيع الاتفاق الاطاري
من اجل ان تستلم السلطه مره اخرى بشراكه
مع الجيش والدعم السريع وتفويض منهما
ووصايه منهما على هذه الحكومه وحمايه لها
في هذه اللحظات دائمه على القوى السياسيه
هاي غير ممثله الان لا تستطيع ان ترد عليك
قد يقول لك قائل لانك سريع حكومه مدنيه
ورئيس حكومه متفق عليه والسيد برهان اطاح
به نعم او وجد الدعم السريع نفسه في مرتين
يلجا اليه المدنيين ليمنحهم السلطه فهو قد
نمت سلطته خلال هذه يعني قوته العسكريه
تقول البدنيه لجات للدعم السريع دكتور نعم
في الاطار كما لجات في الوثيقه الدستوريه
في الوث السوريه الاولى وقعت شراكه
يعني
جيش حديث دكتور
شراكه سلطه يمنحها السلاح يعني هذا هو
الحديث في الوثيقه الدستوريه الاولى الجيش
والدعم السريع وقعوا اتفاق وثيقه دستوريه
منح السلطه للمدنيين في شراكه يحميها
السلاح الاطاري جاء بنفس الطريقه سلطه
مدنيه بشراكه مع السلاح يعني السلاح هو
مانع السلطه طيب اصبح لديهم الكلام غير
دقيق ويحتاج الى الى رد دعنا لنا نتطرق
اليها ان الجهه السياسيه
يملك السلاح الذي يستطيع ان يستولي به على
السلطه بنفسه
اعد ان تحرك في 15 ابريل ليستلم السلطه
هذا التوصيف ما حدث يعني طيب ما رايك سيد
عمران بما قاله الدكتور اسامه
ما قاله الدكتور اسامه هذا يعني يدل على
الاستهجان والسفريه صراحه لانه انا لا
ادري من يخاطب يخاطب نفسه او يخاطب الشعب
السوداني الذي كان شاهدا على كل هذه
التطورات منذ سقوط البشير يعني السيد
هيمتي هو يعني في بادي اصور هو من انضم
لصوت الشعب وهو
من انضم للشعب
واسمع الشعب عندما جاء البرهان نفسه كان
بعيدا عن المشهد البرهان نفسه ومن اتى
وقال له انا لا استلم هذه السلطه بغير
السيد حميدان عندما جاءت وحتى في في
الوثيقه الدستوريه هي لم تنص يعني صراحه
على دمج الدعم السريع وذلك برغبه البرهان
البرهان هو هو الرافد بان تضم في ذلك
الحين عند الدعم السريع لمؤسسه الجيش
يريدها ان تكون مستقله كما كانت وعندما
جاءت
الانقلاب 25 اكتوبر وجاء الايطالي عندما
جاء الايطالي يعني الايطالي ليس ما بين
الجيش
والسياسيه كما يزعم ضيفه انما كان هنالك
مسهلين ايضا من الايجات هنالك الاتحاد
الافريقي
وهذه هو القوه المدنيه السياسيه الذي
يرفضها ضيفا اذا عندما جاء هذا الاتفاق
كان موقفه الجيش وكان في ذلك الحين
الحميديه
على كل النقاط هذه النقطه لان هذا ليس ليس
موضوعنا في في الحلقه وابقى معك السيد
عمران كيف تقرا دلاله خلو خطاب السيد
البرهان من اي مسار تفاوضى كيف كيف ترون
هذا
وهذا هو الخطاب الذي يعني يعد له نظام
السابق والحركه الاسلاميه لان اي عمليه
تفاوض مع الد
عم لهذه يعني ان الجيش سوف يكون بعيد عن
المشهد السياسي وبعود الجيش عن المشهد
مشهد السياسي ذلك يعني ان الحركه
الاسلاميه والنظام السابق يفقد كل
الامتيازات التي كان يتميز بها خلال
الثلاثين عاما فبالتالي هم يراهنون على
استمراريه هذه الحرب او القضاء على الدعم
السريع لذلك الان هو لا يتحدث عن تفاوض
لانه اذا تحدث عن اي تفاوض لا بد
من واذا كان دعم طرفا فيه فبالتالي الدعم
السريع يقف امام تطلعات النظام السابق في
العوده الى السلطه لذلك والان البرهان حتى
البرهان نفسه القرارات التي يتحدث عنها
الضيف وقال انه يتحدث
باريحيه وبشجاعه والذكر هذا كل هذه
الخطابات النظام السابق نحن نعلم جيدا ان
قبل الحرب يوم سته ابريل جلس
[موسيقى]
قوات الدعم السريع ليست حركه مطلبيه وليست
حركه سياسيه هي مجرد قوه عسكريه تمردت على
الجيش هي كانت جزء من النظام السابقه الذي
يتحدث عنه
المستشار سيد عمران والسيد المستشار هي
كانت جزء من النظام السابق وهي جلست مع
ارباب النظام السابق وحكمت معهم البلاد
وثم بعد الثوره ان حازت مع مع الجيش الى
الثوره وتمددت وتوسعت الى ان وصلت الى
نقطه اصبحت قادره فيها على التمرد على
الجيش واستلام السلطه الجيش مسار جدا
المسار في جده وصل الى اتفاق المساف في
جده وصل الى اتفاق وبعد الاتفاق تمت هدنه
لمده سبع ايام واتفقوا على خروج قوات
الدعم السريع من المنشات المدنيه والمرافق
من الاعيان المدنيه ومن المنشات والمرافق
الخدميه وبماذا لا يعود وقت جدا للتفاوض
لاستكمال التفاوض الدكتور لانه لم ينفذ
هذا الشرط
ويتعنت الدعم السريع في انه لا يريد ان
يخرج من الخرطوم ولا من بيوت المواطنين بل
ينفي انه موجود في بيوت المواطنين على
لسان مستشاري رغم ان الكل يعلم انه الان
موجود في داخل بيوت المواطنين في الخرطوم
وفي المرافق الحيويه وفي المستشفيات
ويرتكب المجازر يوميا في الخرطوم تعال
نسال السيد عمران مباشره السيد عمران
لماذا لا تقطعون حجه الجيش بانكم متواجدون
في المنشات المدنيه ومنازل المدنيين
وتنسحبون ليعود مسار جده التفاوضي
اول حاجه بالنسبه
المدنيين
والمنشات الحي الكهرباء والمياه هنالك ان
تم تكوين لجنه خمسه زائد خمسه وقفت على
هذا الامر بنفسها
واخرجت قرار وعرضته
للوساطه اكدوا فيه ان اقول هذه المناطق
حتى المستشفيات من قوات الدعم السريع
بالنسبه للمناطق التي تم الاستيل عليها
المناطق مثل مثل
القصر الجمهوري التسليح المناطق التسليح
الحربي كل هذه الاشياء لا يمكن يعني
تسليمها الان والان الطيران يضرب في
قواتنا كيف يعني بالمنطق الان حتى الحرب
لم تضع اوزارها كيف انت تطلب من قواتنا ان
تخرج خارج الخرطوم وتسلم هذه المناطق
والطيران حتى الان يضرب فيها
نحن لا نامن هذا النظام هذا النظام غدار
هذا النظام لا مصداقيه له هبه هذه الحرب
قبلها بيوم اتفق البرهان ان يجلس ويوقف
على الاتفاق الاطري مع مع القوه السياسيه
لكنه رفض الحضور واغلقت تليفونه في صبايا
صبيحه اليوم ضرب مقر الدعم فبالتالي نحن
لا نثق فيه اذا كانوا جاء الدين في المضيق
قدما في هذه الايقاف هذا الحرف هذا الذي
توقفوا هذا يا اخي
بحث عن المباريات هم لا يحبون ان تقف هذه
الحرب لا نناقون ان اناقش في المحور
الاخير هذه هذه النقطه فرص ايقاف الحرب
خطاب السيد البرهان تزامن مع استمرار
الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مواقع ادب العاصمه الخرطوم وفي مدينه
نيالا بولايه جنوب دارفور التي تدور فيها
منذ عده ايام معارك وصفت بانها الاعنف بين
الجانبين منذ مده زاد وطاتها ما يجري داخل
احياء المدينه السكنيه الامر الذي ادى الى
مقتل وجرح نحو 200 مدني خلال اليومين
الاخيرين الى جانب نزوح كثيرين طلبا
للنجاه وبحسب مراسل جزيره فان الجيش منخرط
ايضا في قتال اخر طرفه الثاني هذه المره
هي قوات الحركه الشعبيه شمال بقياده عبد
العزيز الحلو التي تبادلت القصف مع قوات
الجيش شرق مدينه كادوقلي عاصمه ولايه جنوب
كردفان دكتور القتال يتوسع وبشكل متوحش
بحسب تقارير الامم المتحده في مناطق
بعينها تحديدا في مناطق في دارفور مسؤوليه
الجميع الان التوصل لوقف لهذا الاقتتال
ولوقف لاطلاق النار ما المسؤوليه التي تقع
على السيد برهان وعلى الجيش في هذا الجانب
يقع على على برهان انه هو المسؤول من
ايقاف هذا التمرد من التوسع
وقوات الدعم السريع في كل هجومها على مدن
دارفور تهاجم المدنيين اكثر من هجومها على
الحاميات العسكريه فعلت ذلك في الجنينه
فعلت ذلك في كاس فعل ذلك في سرب يا دكتور
ايضا
اربعه اشهر مضت ولم يستطع الجيش ان يحسم
عسكريا اليس نعم لا التوجه الى ماذا يطول
امه هذه الحرب لان الدعم السريع واحد من
الاشياء الان انه تحول الى عصابات ترتكب
الجرائم بحق المدنيين في كل اطراف السودان
الشيء الثاني دخول اطراف خارجيه القرار
بيدها اكثر من انه بيد قوات الدعم السريع
تطيل امه هذه الحرب وتغذيها وتزيدها ولذلك
قوات الدعم السريعه الان امامها
مكتوب في جده كل المطلوب منها الالتزام
بهذا الاتفاق وتقف النار في كل اطراف
السودان لماذا لا تريد ان
تلتزم باتفاق جده الذي وقعته بنفسها لانه
هنالك اطراف دكتور
انسحب من المنشات المدنيه وهو لا يستطيع
ان يقنع بهذه الطريقه يعني هذا الكلام كذب
هذا الكلام كذب ما زال الدعم السريع موجود
الان في بيوت المواطنين حتى نيال التي
دخلها البارح دخلوا الى بيوت المواطنين
ونهبوها هم يدخلون بيوت المواطنين في كل
السودان كل يوم وينهبوه في كل مكان توجد
قواتهم يوجد نهب للمواطنين
يقول بان كلامك كذب وما انك انكم ما زلتم
تستهدفون المدنيين
وتتواجدون في منشات ومنازل المدنيين لذا
لا يستطيع الجيش ان يقصفكم ولا يستطيع
بالتالي ان يتحاور معكم
اول حاجه سيدي الفاضل
متناقض اول حاجه انا اريد ان اتحدث عن
الجزئيه التي تحدث فيها عن توسع ركعه
القتال لاسيما في مناطق دارفور النظام
السابق استغلت تلك المناطق واستغل الفقر
والجهل الذي
نورث تجاه تلك المكونات بان سلح جزء منهم
وعامل معهم الان النظام السابق حتى يعود
للسلطه لابد من ان يخلق فوضى خلاقه
فبالتالي وزع الاسلحه ودع البرهان صراحه
لتسليح الشعب السوداني كله ولم يجد من
يربي هذه الدعوه الا في تلك المناطق الهشه
فبالتالي هو الان اشعل تلك الحرب حتى حتى
تكون هنالك فوضى خلابه وتكون هنالك مساهمه
حتى يجد
ان تكون هنالك تسويه من خلال هذه التسويه
ان يكون النظام السابق جزء منها لذلك هذه
الحرب الان مشتعله الشيء الثاني الذي
يتحدث عنه ضيفك عن بيوت المواطنين هذه يا
اخي هذه يعني اكذوبه يريدونه ان يطيلوا
بها ابدا الحظ البويضه المواطنين البرهان
يتحدث به اذا كان حريص على المواطنين
لماذا يحسبهم بالطيران لماذا يدمر بيوتهم
لماذا يقتلهم قتل اكثر من ما قتلته الحرب
يا اخي هذا كلام كذب وكلام خالي من الصحه
تماما عندي تحدث عن ان هنالك جهاد خارجيه
الجهات الخارجيه الان ايران دخلت بسقلها
وهي الان الذي يعني حتى الطيران الايراني
يضرب هنالك
دكتور انت قلت بان خطاب السيد البرهان هو
وصف الان هذه الحرب اذا استغرقه اربعه
اشهر ليوصف هذه الحرب كم من الوقت سيستغرق
لكي ينهيها سواء كان بالحسم او بالتفاوض
هذه الحرب مفروضه على الشعب السوداني
والمفروض على الجيش السوداني وبها جهات
خارجيه تغذيها
ندفع بما نستطيع حتى تنتهي هذه الحرب
بالحسم العسكري او بالتفاوض اذا التزمت
دعم السريع
بمقررات جده للتفاوض او اذا قامت القوه
المدنيه السودانيه بايجاد
حل سياسي اعلى مما هو مطروح الان في
الساحه يوقف هذه الحرب شكرا هذه هي طرق
وقف الحرب في السودان ووقف جرائم الدعم
السريع التي يرتكبها في حربه ضد الشعب
السوداني شكرا لكم الدكتور اسامه عيدروس
في الدوحه والسيد عمران عبد الله في لندن
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه الى
اللقاء بامر الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]